hallo mein name ist programm liebe
freunde ich sind sie mal wieder nicht
alleine vom antrieb sondern letztlich
auch mal so motiviert sein wie du dann
habe ich mache für das heutige video
etwas was es so noch nie auf einem kanal
gemacht habe denn wir sind heute
zusammen auf der plattform tv unterwegs
kennt ihr noch damals hätte roulette wir
machen jetzt einfach skype mit fremden
menschen
wahrscheinlich ist lukas geworden
ich werde wie bruder so manchen preis
und seine brechen lassen
ganz kurz mal warten
schicken wir in einem youtube-video ja
wenn ihr möchtet ja ja bitte
die kommen aus österreich die kommissare
schweine deutschland pudel bayern ja
hallo ihr seid bleiben bürger sind im
und um damit die seit dem youtube-video
dabei egal du hast so unnormal weißer
hase mit dem blond vorne legal deine
haare sondern wollte irgendwie grüßen
oder so der vorhin aus bayern hat seine
mutter geprüft
klar kannst du die farben von einem led
im hintergrund ändern hubland grün sieht
dann aus wenn die kein alkohol bekommen
also machten youtube und wollt ihr mir
sagen wollt ihr ihn grüßen
schlussmann unterhalten der wand hallo
es geht woher kommt ihr sachsen wo ist
das denn nochmal alter im norden
seid ihr ein paar ich lieg auch mit
manchen männern somit dem ich nicht
zusammen es ist jeder kann
hallo wir haben mit meinem hintergrund
stellen aufweist du umschalten nicht
einig wir haben halt nicht mal
angekündigt dass wir das machen ja
deswegen so frank rost jetzt soll
hat sich gut auf jeden fall möchte dir
begrüßen
[Musik]
denn hier ganzheit weggedrückt und luca
doch ich bin sandra hallo schwer
ja was soll ich sagen ist dass im
hintergrund die maske des geldes so mit
menschen ist jetzt mein gott das ist
sprachen lernen wie soll man das denn
trinken bekam ist ein bisschen schief ja
damit wir auf einer höhe
wenn die kämen gerade wer ja und ich
schlage
hallo hatte was seid ihr recht nicht
wenn leute so emotional plötzlich danke
du bist heute auch im video dabei ich
grüße meine beste freundin christine es
geht habe ich so wie jeder denkt wir
sind krasse treffen
ich dachte mein block setzen kreis
junger denker ag
meine schwester war ja klar macht
projekte und eile hintergrund junge
junge alter stone island
[Musik]
auf seiner seite
ja ich draußen alltag jedoch gleichwohl
[Gelächter]
die schöne stimme ja hallo hallo
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
immer mehr leute da wie alt seid ihr
jetzt nur 13
so wie mein bruder nein ich grüße die
luise handeln aufgerufen daneben an
[Musik]
es hat gerade einer vor ich mir erzählt
dass ihr hier seid und hat gesagt wenn
ich glück habe treffe ich euch also
erkrankt man rechnet gar nicht damit
dass die leute online sind und man
trifft hier dann aber ich muss das so
sein ergebnis soll alle leute daraus
motivieren also mein vater ist jetzt
viereinhalb jahren an krebs verstorben
und das war halt also für mich war das
halt ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
schlimm
ich hatte dann drei monate später
stiefvater und man gut als dass ein
freund des seit zwei monaten ihr kind
erwarte
und das ist einfach alles richtig also
an alle leute denen so etwas passiert
ist einfach richtig richtig richtig die
reden richtig für den psychologen sagen
bringt absolut gar nichts also
beispielsweise nicht geholfen aber wenn
man
richtig richtig richtig viele freunde
hat und mit jedem richtig richtig viel
drüber redet damit verbessern dann nur
noch nie so oft es muss sich einfach
bewusst erst mal mein beileid und ganz
viel erfolgt in der zeit auf jeden fall
ganz kurz bevor wir uns weiter
unterhalten ist es für dich feiern wir
nicht mehr geraten video auf das was mit
drin ist oder sonnenhaus schneiden das
ist voll in ordnung das ist von unseren
kirchen 8 uhr erzählt es uns gerade im
vertrauen und würde ich die cd alles
wird das ich möchte einfach dass das
jeder weiß weil ich habe auch eine
gewisse reichweite auf die tor geklappt
jetzt 48.000 förderung danke dir auf
jeden fall für deine worte ich glaube da
können auf jeden fall viele was mit
anfangen gut euch noch ein spieltag der
liga das ist ein krankes schlusswort auf
jeden fall
[Musik]